[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست لو الحياه هتدي لك ضهرها
100 مره وهتمد لك ايديها مره واحده بس يا
ترى هتكون واعي كفايه زي بطل فيلمنا
النهارده انك تمسك بايدك واسنانك في المره
دي فيلم النهارده يعتبر من اهم الافلام في
تاريخ السينما الامريكيه والوقت نزوله نال
اعجاب المشاهدين بشكل كبير عمل ضجه في
صلاه العرض وخلق عصر جديد من السينما فيلم
رسالته الصادقه وواضحه وملموسه صديقي
لدرجه انها هتحققت بالفعل لبطل في الفيلم
في حياته رساله تكمن في ان ايمانك بنفسك
وبقدراتك ميه في الميه هيوصلك للنجاح مهما
طال طريقك ومهما بان صعب النهارده خلونا
نروح سوا لما وراء الفيلم الاسطوري للرائع
سيلفستر ستالون راقي الفيلم الحائز على
تلات جوائز اوسكار لافضل فيلم وافضل اخراج
وافضل مونتاج بدا بدايه بسيطه جدا لو تعرف
فكرته بدات في لحظه وقصته اتكتبت في تلات
ايام ونجاح سنين سلفستر ستالون قبل فيلم
راقي مكنش ممثل كبير ولا معروف ولا كان
ممثل غني ولكنه كان راقي كان بيملك روح
راقي اللحوح وقبل ما حتى يكتب الفيلم او
يفكر فيه فكره الفيلم جت له في يوم وهو
بيتفرج على العظيم محمد علي كلاي ولاعب
بوكسين مغمور اسمه
على الرغم من انه لاعب غير مؤهل سنه سته
وتلاتين سنه ما بيمتلكش اي خبره ولو حتى
قريبه لمحمد علي الا انه فضل مصر على
استكمال الماتش لحد ما غلب كليه ومن وسط
كل العيون المبهوره بالنتيجه الغير متوقعه
كان في عين شافتها قصه نجاح لازم تتخلد
قصه راجل هيقف في وش الحياه كانها عدو
وهيحاول يغلبها علشان يوصل لحلمه
بعد الماتش ده فضل تلات ايام بيرسم في
شخصيه راقي حياته صراعاته فقر وحلمه
وتحقيق الحلم ده واللي خلى الشخصيه تكون
مرسومه بشكل دقيق جدا وما تكونش صعبه على
ستالون ان هو كان شايف نفسه في راقي
الشخصيه المستضعفه الفقيره اللي بتحاول
وبتسع علشان تلاقي نقطه نور لان ده ما
كانش غريب عليه فالصالون قال في حوار له
انه قبل راقي اضطر يبيع كلبه لانه كان لسه
ناقل كاليفورنيا وما كانش معاه فلوس ياكل
نفسه او ياكل الكلب بتاعه وبعد ما انتهى
السله راح يعرضه على شركات الانتاج وبدون
تردد هم حبوا السيناريو جدا وحبوا القصه
لكن محبوش ان اللي يمثلها يكون سلفستر
ستالون شيء طبيعي يكون ممثل مغمور وما حدش
هيدخل الفيلم بطوله ممثل مغمور وحاولوا
يقنعوا ستالون ان هو يتنازل عن بطوله
الفيلم في مقابل 360 الف دولار المهم ان
دور روكي ما يكونش له في اللحظه دي افتكر
ان كل اللي هو بيملكه في البنك هم 106
دولار بس وان هو باع الكلب بتاعه عشان
يدفع الفواتير يعني المفروض ده عرض ما
يترفضش بس هو رفضه تعليقا على رافضه ده
قال في واحد من لقاءاته فكرت مع نفسي انا
كده كده فقير والحياه الكويسه حتى انا مش
متعود عليها يعني مش هتفرق كتير كده كده
هعرف اعيش وعرفت بقرار نفسي ان لو بعت
السيناريو حقق نجاح كويس قوي وانا ما كنتش
البطل ساعتها فعلا مش هعرف اعيش وبيكمل
انه كان عارف ان قراره في مخاطره كبيره
وان لو خسر مش هيخسر لوحده بس هو كان مؤمن
بنفسه وبحلمه وقرر يغامر المنتجين قرروا
يتامروا معاه ولكن بمزانيه قليله جدا
مليون دولار ما فيش غيرهم وما تفتكرش ان
وقتها ده كان رقم حتى في السبعينيات
المليون دولار كانوا ميزانيه انتاج ضعيفه
عشان ينزل فيلم روكي للسينمات ويكسر كل
التوقعات ويلاقي رد فعل كبير من الجمهور
وتهافت على جميع صلاه العرض لحضوره
وبينتهي به الامر للتسع ترشيحات لاسكر كسب
منهم ثلاثه واجمالي بقيمه 200 مليون دولار
ويحتل المرتبه 78 في قائمه افضل 100 فيلم
في التاريخ شخصيه راقي في الفيلم ما تقلش
اصرار وطموح عن شخصيه السلوم في الحقيقه
فهو ملاكم فقير بيشتغل شغل ما بيحبوش جت
له فرصه يكسب لقب بطوله العالم للوزن
التقيل لما هيتم اختياره كمنافس لبطل
العالم الحالي ازاي راقي هيحاول باقصى جهد
ويستغل الفرصه دي وازاي هيشتغل على نفسه
تدريبه ورحلته مع المدرب بتاعه والبنت
اللي بيحبها وايمانهم بيه وبقدراته لحظه
انتصاره بعد المشقه دي كلها فيلم مؤثر بكل
المقاييس نجاح في المراكي ما كانش ملموس
على شبكه تذاكر بس ولكن في جيل الشباب
وقتها كمان فبعد عرض الفيلم زادت نسبه
الشباب اللي بيلعبوا رياضه خاصه الملاكمه
واصبح راقي بعدها رمز شعبي وفضل لفتره
طويله هو بالنسبه لهم الفيلم كمان كان له
عوامل نجاح تانيه غير مصداقيته وهي ادوات
المخرج فبنلاقي مثلا استغلال كويس قوي
للموسيقى واللي تعتبر من العناصر الاساسيه
في اي فيلم وفيلم راقي تم استخدامها بشكل
متميز وذكي علشان تلعب على المشاعر
فمثلا اغنيه جانا فلاي ناو استخدمها في
الفيلم علشان تعبر عن التحدي والاصرار
وتدي الفيلم طابع مؤثر وملهم واللي
بالمناسبه كانت نمبر وان هيت سنه 1977 بعد
اصدارها كمان الاخراج نفسه كان متقن ومؤثر
والمخرج استخدم تقنيات اخراجيه مختلفه
علشان يقدر يوصل مشاعر كل مشهد كما هو
مطلوب واللي بفضله الفيلم قدر يوصل رسالته
ويؤثر في المشاهدين باختلاف اعمارهم
الاضاءه والتصوير في الفيلم كانوا اهم
عوامل نجاحه تقريبا وده بسبب استخدام
تقنيات اضاءه وتصوير مختلفه زي السلوم
موشن والاضات العكسيه والمتغيره والمتشتته
كل تقنيه كان بيتم استخدامها على حسب نوع
المشهد والمشاعر المفروض توصل للجمهور ضيف
على كل العناصر دي ممثلين ادوا ادوارهم
ببراعه جديده علشان يطلع في الاخر تجربه
سينمائيه متكامله فيلم راقي اللي يبدو في
ظاهره انه مجرد فيلم رياضي هو في اصله
حاله انسانيه دراميه بيعلم الاصرار
والتحدي وعدم الياس الايمان بنفسك ومقدرتك
بيعلمك اهميه الناس اللي موجودين في حياتك
واللي من غير دعمهم وقوفهم جنبك عمرك ما
هتقدر تكمل فيلم بيخلق جواك قيم زي الحب
والانسانيه والتضحيه والتعاون المزيج ده
ما قصرش في الجمهور بس ده قصر في صناعه
الافلام ككل لان كتير من صناعه الافلام
اعتبروه مصدر الهام ليهم ان ازاي ممكن
ندمج ما بين العناصر الدراميه والرياضيه
في فيلم واحد ويكون فيلم ناجح والجنبر دي
من الافلام بقى ليها جمهور خاص لحد
النهارده استمر نجاح فيلم راقي ممتد بجميع
اجزائه التاني والتالت والرابع بارباح
خياليه واصطفاف جماهير كبير اما الجزء
الخامس والسادس ما قابلوش نفس النجاح
القوي ده علشان يرجع سنه 2015 و 2018
بجزئين جداد لتكمله السلسله تحت اسم كريد
واللي حصل الجزء الاول منها على ترشيح
للاسكر وارباحهم مجتمعين تجاوزه ال 200
مليون دولار ده غير الفيلم الجديد اللي
نزل سنه 2023 علشان تتختم السلسله ختمه
قويه زي ما كانت بدايتها قويه ولو في يوم
يقست او حسيت ان حلمك صعب او بعيد افتكر
انس
كان معكم محمود النجار واستناني الحلقه
اللي جايه في حلقه جديده اللي ما وراء
فيلم ملحمه جديد من بودكاست ما وراء
الافلام
[موسيقى]